Transcriber: ÖZGE İŞBECER
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
Biraz heyecanlıyım tabii.
Heyecanlı olmamak mümkün değil.
Ben kısaca size hikâyemi anlatacağım
ama hani böyle herkesin fotoğrafı vardır
ya küçükken aşçı olmak isterdim
ve elimde kepçem, elimde mikserim öyle
fotoğraflarım vardır.
Her tarafım una bulanmış hâlde.
Küçük çocukluğum böyle geçti der bazıları
ama benim hiç böyle bir hayatım olmadı.
Çocukluğuma dair, yemekle ilgili
hiçbir anım olmadı.
Hatta hiçbir merakım da olmadı
çünkü mutfakta sürekli bir şeyler
yapılırdı ve ben sadece sürekli bunu
gözlemleyen bir roldeydim.
Üniversiteye kadar aslında hiç
mutfağa girmedim diyebilirim.
Mutfakta sadece gözlemci ruh içindeydim.
Üniversiteye gittiğim zaman sağlıklı
beslenmeye olan bir merakım oluştu.
O zamanlar Ayşegül Çoruhlu’nun bir kitabı
elime geçti, Alkali Beslenme
ve sonra
Tokuz Ama Açız kitapları vardı.
Bu kitapları okuduğumda
ben çok etkilendim.
Aslında bir gecede bütün beslenme
düzenimi bir gecede değiştirdim.
O kitapları okuduktan sonra çok radikal
bir karardı ama beni çok etkilemişti.
Özellikle beslenmenin hücresel boyutta ele
alınması bana çok farklı bir bakış
açısı gelmişti ve bütün beslenme
alışkanlığımı bir gecede değiştirdim.
Bana sorarlardı nasıl bu sağlıklı beslenme
işine başladın, nasıl bu işe
giriştin diye.
Aslında o kitaptan sonra başladı.
Şimdi düşünüyorum.
Evet ben o kitabı okudum ve bir anda
beslenme düzenimi değiştirmeye,
bedenimi daha sağlıklı
bir hâle getirmeye karar verdim.
O kitaplardan sonra evde kendimce böyle
tarifler üretmeye, içerikler üretmeye,
bir şeyler denemeye başladım.
Bu ellerim bir şey yapmalıydı, bir
şey karalamalıydı bir şey yaratmalıydım
hep baktığımda bir şeyler yapma
ihtiyacı, bu elleri değerlendirme, kendi
yeteneklerimi keşfetmeye yönelik bir
çabam olmuş küçüklüğüme baktığımda.
Üniversitede bu tarifleri içerikleri
yavaş yavaş üretmeye başladığımda giderek
bir merakım oluşmaya başladı.
Spor yapmaya başladım işte
pilates yapıyorum.
Zaten çocukluğumda aktif bale yapıyordum.
Bir spor geçmişim de vardı.
Dedim ki ben spor yapabiliyorum.
Sağlıklı beslenmeyi seviyorum.
Üniversitede işletme bölümünü
seçtim ama biliyorum.
Yani işletmeye gidiyorum ama
yapmayacağım hiçbir şey biliyorum.
Ben başka bir şey yapmalıyım yani benim
dünyam bambaşka bir şey.
İşletmeye gittim,
hepiniz illaki vardır.
Üniversiteye gidersiniz ama bir şey
yapmayacağınızı bilirsiniz ama aileniz
mutlu olsun,
ona bir diploma vereyim istersiniz.
Çünkü aileniz bunu sizden ister.
Aslında benim için de böyle oldu.
Biliyordum.
O üniversite yıllarımda ben başka
bir şeyler yapacağım, başka
bir dünya kuracağım.
Ama bu hayal inanarak ya da bir
şeyi hayal ederek geçmedi.
Sadece o anda anın keyfini çıkararak,
kendimi keşfederek geçti.
Annemler, üniversiteden sonra bana
profesyonel bir makine almıştı.
Ben onlardan ne istersin
mezuniyet hediyesi dediklerinde
ben bir profesyonel fotoğraf makinası
istiyorum demiştim.
Çünkü yemek fotoğraflarımı çekiyordum.
Kendimi çekiyordum, çekmeyi seviyordum.
Babamdan da gördüğüm kadarıyla demek
ki bir yeteneğim vardı belki de.
Benden istedikleri fotoğraf
makinası, istediğim fotoğraf makinasıyla
yemek fotoğraflarımı çekmeye devam ettim
ve blog yazılarımı serviste iken
yazmaya devam ediyordum.
Hayatım günümün 4 saati serviste geçiyordu
ama o serviste geçen saati
blog yazarak kendi sevdiğim şeyleri
yaparak geçirmeye devam ettim aslında
ve üniversitede aslında bu temellerini
attığım sağlıklı beslenmeye olan ilgimi
profesyonelleştirmeye karar verdim.
Çünkü ben bu alanda kendimi çok daha rahat
ve iyi hissetmiştim ve bu alanda
profesyonelleşmeyi istiyordum,
bu buna karar vermiştim.
Sağlıklı beslenmek o zamanlar
çok bilinen bir şey değildi.
Sağlıklı beslenme dediğiniz zaman
aklımıza sadece böyle
etin daha buharda pişmiş hali,
sebzelerin buharda pişmiş hali.
Veganlık, bitki temelli beslenmek ne;
bunların hiçbiri yoktu
ve Türkiye’de böyle bir eğitim
alabileceğim bir yer olduğunu görmedim.
Araştırdım,
böyle bir eğitim hiçbir okulda yoktu.
Derken yollarım bir şekilde Amerika’da
Los Angeles’ta tam Venice caddesinin orada
Matthew Kenney Culinary diye bir
okulla kesişti yollarım.
Bu okulu internetten buldum.
Daha önce Amerika’ya
hiç gitmedim bu arada.
Tek başıma nasıl giderim?
Hiçbir şekilde bilmiyorum.
Biraz da korkum var.
Hani Amerika'ya nasıl giderim?
Orada nasıl kalırım, nasıl bir yaşam olur?
Ve okulun ücreti de 6 bin dolar
civarındaydı o zamanlar.
O zamanın kuru tabii ki de
şimdiki gibi değil
ama çok yüksek bir rakamdı ve
benim böyle bir param yoktu.
Aylık bir maaşım vardı modellikten gelen
ama bunu karşılayacak bir para değildi bu.
Nasıl yaparım derken bu parayı
nasıl karşılayabilirim?
Derken bana şöyle bir fırsat sundular.
İlk 1500 dolarını sen peşinatını öde,
kalanını taksit taksit ödersin.
İyi de 1500 dolar nasıl ödeyeceğim?
Öyle bir param yok benim.
O zamanki erkek arkadaşım, şimdiki
eşim dedi ki bu parayı öderiz.
Kendisi antrenör.
Ben bir öğrencimden bunu,
3 aylık bir parayı alabilirim.
Ve senin bu okul şeyini karşılayabiliriz.
Böyle yaptı, ödedik
ve ben o okula gittim.
Amerika’ya gittim ama gidişim şöyle oldu.
Kadıköy’de 1+1 çok küçük bir evde,
geceleri böyle yorgan altında Amerika’da
kalacağım yerleri arayarak.
Bilmiyorum
korkuyorum, tek başımayım ama beni
cesaretlendiren biri var yanında
yapabilirsin diyor.
Ben de evet yapabilirim herhalde
gidebilirim diye.
Evlere bakıyorum airbnb’den,
bu kadar kalacak da şeyim yok.
Bu kadar lüks bir yerde kalamam.
Kalma ücreti de benim için çok önemli.
Airbnb’de böyle Guatemala’dan Amerika’ya
göçmüş bir ailenin yanında bir oda buldum.
Aile iki odası vardı evinin.
Bir tanesinin kirası daha ucuzdu.
Tabii ki onu seçtim ve Amerika’yla,
o evle görüşmeye başladım.
Derken o evle anlaştık.
O evle oraya gideceğim.
Amerika zamanı geldi.
Ben taksitleri maaşımdan tamamını
neredeyse aylık taksitlerini ödedim.
Bana çok bir şey kalmıyordu ama iyiydi.
Ben bir hayalim vardı ve bu istediğimi
gerçekleştirecektim bana yeterdi.
Bu aylar geçti ben Amerika'ya gittim.
Hayatımın herhalde en güzel bir
1,5 ayıydı diyebilirim size.
Böyle geleceğe ışınlanmış gibi oldum.
Çünkü benim dünyamda bitki temelli ve
vegan bir dünyada,
Amerika’da olmak
geleceğe ışınlanmak gibiydi.
Sizin daha hayal bile
edemeyeceğiniz şeylere.
Onlar çoktan market raflarına koymuşlardı
ve çok ütopik bir yerdi.
Sanki böyle bir film setinin içine
gelmiş gibiydim.
Orada olduğumuz süre boyunca bütün okulun
imkanlarını değerlendiririm.
Deneyebildiğim kadar mutfakta kendi
reçetelerimi denemeye çalıştım.
Çünkü mutfak sınırsız,
size bir çalışma alanı vermişlerdi.
Çalışma sınırsız, serbestti;
tüm malzemeleri kullanabiliyordunuz.
Ama bir şey vardı,
oradaki malzemeler bizim Türk mutfağıyla
çok paralellik göstermiyordu.
Biraz farklı bir mutfaktı.
Türkiye'ye döndüğümde ben içerik
üretmeye devam ederim diyordum.
Blog yazılarıma devam ederim diyordum.
Bu sırada ben bir Youtube kanalı açmıştım.
Dedim ki, ben insanlarla bu mutfağı
daha çok tanıtmalıyım.
Sağlıklı tariflerimi paylaşmaya
devam etmeliyim.
Youtube kanalı açtığımda dedim
ki bu benim alanım.
Ben etkileşim halinde olmayı seviyorum,
paylaşmayı seviyorum
ve bu kanalla devam ederim.
Aldığım eğitim bu kanalı destekler.
Ne olacağını bilmiyorum ama bir şekilde
ben buradan bir iş fırsatı yaratabilirim
diye düşündüm.
Bir hayalim yok.
Bir kafe açmak, bir restoran açmak,
bir yerde çalışmak
bir amaç değildi benim için.
Sadece istiyordum.
Bu mutfakla alakalı
bir şeyler yapmak istiyordum.
Türkiye’ye döndüğüm zaman dedim
ki burada devam ederim ben.
İçerik üretmeye devam ederim
çünkü hayalim bu, isteğim bu.
Derken bana bir iş fırsatı doğdu.
Bir arkadaşımız kafe açıyordu ve dedi ki
“Beril sen tatlıları güzel yaparsın.
Bu mutfağın tatlarını sen yap.”
Tamam dedim, güzel bir fırsat.
Ne kaybedebilirim ki yani
hiç maaş bile sormadım ne alacağımı
çünkü bu bir deneyimdi ve güzel bir
şeydi, bunu kabul etmeliydim.
Kabul ettim ve kabul ettikten sonra şimdi
çok sevdiğim bir ablamız bana inanarak
dedi ki, “Beril ben
buraya yatırım yapmak istiyorum.
Sana melek yatırımcı olacağım.”
Şimdi melek yatırımcı yatırımcı olacak
ve beni ortak olarak
oraya dahil etmek istiyor.
Tamam, dedim.
Yine ne kaybedebilirim ki
ortak olarak orada kafede sadece pastacı,
sadece pasta yapan bir insan rolünden
bir anda ortak pozisyona düştüm.
Ama şöyle düşünün, şimdi ben ailemde
hiç ticaret görmedim.
Borçlanmak nedir bilmiyorum,
ticaret hiç bilmiyorum.
Borçla yaşamanın, borçlanarak bir yer
açmanın, ilerlemenin, şubeleşmenin
böyle bir dünyaya doğmadığım için
biraz korkutucu geldi başta.
Evet ama bana verilen rolü en iyi
şekilde yapacağımı düşünüyordum.
Aileme dedim ki, ben bir kafe açıyorum.
Böyle bir fırsat var.
O zaman babam bana şöyle bir şey söyledi.
Peki dedi kızım,
senin sigortanı kim ödeyecek?
Baba, dedim,
ortak olarak giriyorum ben bu işe.
Sigortamı mı düşünüyorsun şu anda?
Çok güzel bir şey değil mi?
Ama o da bilmiyordu aslında.
Yani o da belki de bu ticaretteki.
Onun için borçlanmak belki
de çok zor bir şeydi.
Belki altından kalkması çok zor bir işti
ve benim bu işe girmemi istemiyordu
belki de o zaman.
Onu çok iyi anlıyorum
ama ben bu işe girdim.
Amerika'daki reçeteleri Türk
versiyonlarına uyarladım.
Kafe bir anda çok popüler oldu.
Çok fazla insan gelmeye başladı.
Biz pasta, tatlı yetiştiremiyoruz.
İnsanlar onun içeriğine
bakmadan geliyorlar.
Ben çiğ beslenme üzerine eğitim almışım
ama pastaların insanlar
çiğ olduğunu bile bilmiyorlar.
Sadece tatlıları güzel diye geliyorlar
ve biz tatlıları yetiştiremiyoruz.
Kafe dolup taşıyor.
Ben sadece üretmeye,
yapmaya devam ediyorum.
Saati, zamanı her şeyi unutmuşum.
Sonra şöyle bir zaman geldi.
Ortakla girdiğiniz zaman işin içine
ortakla sizin
beklentileriniz uyuşmayabiliyor.
Biz de böyle bir dönüm noktasına girdik.
Ortağım daha çok üretmek,
daha çok ticaret yapmak,
daha çok şey olsun istiyor işte.
Kahvaltı da olsun, öğle yemeği de olsun
akşam yemeği de olsun,
her şey olsun, daha çok kazanalım, her
şey olsun bu dünyada diyor
ve biz buraya girdikten sonra
onunla beraber
dedim ki, “Ben bu
ortakla bu işi yapamayacağım.
Bu ortakla benim fikirlerim olmuyor.
Biz aynı dünyada değiliz.
Beni geriye çekiyor.
Onun fikirleriyle benim fikirlerim
aynı yönde değil.”
Ve benim orada bir karar
vermem gerekiyordu
ve bazen böyle bir fırsat çıkar karşınıza.
Ama o fırsatı yakalamak için de
ardında bıraktığınız o kapıları
tamamen kapatmak gerekir.
Benim için de öyle bir noktadaydı.
Bir kapı vardı;
o kapıyı açıp kendi isteklerim, hayallerim
doğrultusunda bir yere gitmek istiyordum
ama arkamdaki kapı da biraz
aralık kalsın işte, ne olur ne olmaz
belki dönerim oraya diye bir endişe vardı.
O kapıyı tamamen kapatmam gerekiyordu
ve ben o kapıyı tamamen kapattım.
Ortakla tüm ilişkilerimi kestim.
Biz bu süreçte -- atölye açmıştım.
Atölyede bitki temelli eğitimler verdik,
artizan vegan peynir eğitimleri verdik.
Aslında sektöre, birçok alanda insana,
yüzlerce insana eğitim verdim burada
ve sektör o zamanlar bir yanda veganlık,
bitki temelli mutfak bir anda bilinir
olmaya başladı
ve ben tam böyle
en yüksekte iken bir anda
o tüm kapıları kapattım.
Dedim ki; ben burada yapamayacağım, ben
istemiyorum, ben ticaret yapmayacağım,
ben ticaret yapamıyorum,
bunu bilmiyorum herhalde.
Yani bunun üstüne gitmenin anlamı yok.
Ben bunu yapamıyorum.
Ortağıma dedim ki, ben yapmayacağım.
Atölye de senin olabilir,
kafe de senin olsun.
Tüm hisselerimi de devrediyorum
ve ben bu işin içinde yokum.
O zaman Instagram’ını yapıyorduk,
Instagram’ı çok popüler bir hâle gelmişti.
Başlarda şöyle bir şeye girdim.
Dedim ki, Instagram’ını büyüttüm.
Bu Instagram’ı bırakmayayım ben.
Kendi yeni atölye açarım,
o Instagram’la devam ederim.
Ama bir şeye başlamak istediğinizde
o arkadaki her şeyi bırakmak gerekiyor
çünkü oraya bir bağınız kaldığı
zaman oradaki sorumluluklar, oradaki
insanların beklentileri sizin yeni işinize
hep engel olmaya çalışıyor.
O yüzden her şeyi bıraktım,
ortakla tüm ilişkimi kestim,
markayla tüm bağlantımı kopardım.
Kafe hâlâ devam ediyor bu arada.
Ben aradan geçen 3 sene oldu
orayı çoktan unuttum aslında
ama insanlar hâlâ
orayı hatırlıyorlar benden dolayı.
Ama benim için orası bitti.
Orayı büyüttüm, başta emek yedim
sonra koştuk ama bitmişti.
Ben kendime yeni bir yol çizdim,
kendime bir atölye tuttum.
Bu atölyede kendi istediğim şeyleri
yapacaktım sadece kimseye bağlı olmadan.
Ta en başa ilk başta istediğim
şeye döndüm.
Ben neydi? Ben içerik üretmek istiyordum,
video çekmek istiyordum,
insanlarla bu heyecanımı
paylaşmak istiyordum.
Daha profesyonel bir şekilde
kardeşimin de desteğiyle
o atölyede videolar çekmeye başladım.
Evet, belki de bir şeyim yoktu,
kazancım yoktu.
Ama biliyordum, istediğim şeyi yapıyorum
ve bunca emek harcıyorum ve bunun bir
karşılığı olacak, illaki olacak.
Derken artizan vegan peynir üretmek
ve bunu bir markalaştırma
fikri de doğdu
ve bununla ilgili bir şeyler
yapmak istiyordum.
O atölyede bir yandan
video çekerek bir yandan
sosyal medyada içeriklerim devam ediyordu.
Birkaç markayla işbirliği yapmıştım.
Bir kazancım vardı.
Kiramı karşılıyordum.
Ar-Ge’m için, peynir üretimi için orada
Ar-Ge’mi karşılayacak bir param vardı.
Bir şekilde döndürüyordum
sonunu düşünmeden.
Peynirleri ürettim, peynirler
çok sevildi, tutuldu.
Güzel de insanların beklentisini
karşılamıştı belki de
ama hep benden bir şey bekleniyordu.
Beril sen, senin potansiyelinin
aşağısında iş yapıyorsun.
Sen daha çok yapmalısın.
Onu da üretmelisin, onu da yapmalısın.
Sen bu potansiyelde değilsin,
bu potansiyeli kullanamıyorsun,
daha çok şey yapmalısın, diyordu insanlar.
Ama ben onlara dönüp şey diyordum.
Ben bunları yapmak istemiyorum,
bunları siz yapmak istiyorsunuz.
Ben o kafeyi açmak benim hayalim değildi,
o kafeyi yönetmek benim hayalim değildi,
ben ticaret yapan bir karakterde
biri değildim.
Ben kendi başıma kendim var olmak,
kendi içeriklerimle
kendi bildiğim doğrularla
ilerlemek istiyordum.
Peynir ürettikten sonra
evet hayalim miydi? Evet.
Onu üretmek benim hayalim miydi? Evet.
Ama o hayale ulaştıktan sonra belki
de hayale kavuşmuş olmanın
coşkusuyla bilmiyorum.
O hayal benim için
tamamen bitti ve dedim ki;
bu iş değil, bu işi yapmayacağım ben.
Hâlâ istiyor olabilirsiniz benim bir
şeyler üretmemi, ama ben içerik üretmeye
ve videolarımı çekmeye
devam etmek istiyorum.
Ben burada çok daha mutluyum.
Mutlu olduğum şeyi yapmalıyım.
O atölyede hem peynirimi satarak
hem videolarımı çekerek
içeriklerimi üreterek zamanım geçti.
Evet, bir şekilde kendimi karşıladım.
Kazancım çok bir şey değildi ama
ihtiyaçlarımı karşılıyordu.
Çok ütopik bir hayallerim yoktu.
Kafe açtıktan sonra şubeleşmek
gibi de bir hayalim yoktu.
Şubeleri açıp kendimi o mutsuzluğa
itmek istemiyordum.
Çünkü onları yönetme gücünü
kendimde bulmuyordum.
Ben o karakterde biri değil, ben kendiyle
olabilen bir karakterdim.
Sonra peynirleri bıraktıktan sonra tamamen
odağımı içerik üretmeye verdim
ve videolarımı çekmeye başladım.
Sosyal medyada çok daha fazla
içerik üretmeye başladım.
Bitki temelli mutfağı
herkesin öğrenmesini istiyordum.
Eğitimler veriyordum ama bu
eğitimler yetmiyordu.
Ben herkesin, tüm Türkiye’de hatta
dünyanın bu mutfağı yaptıklarımı
görmesini ve bilmesini istiyordum.
Ve içerik üretmeye devam ettim.
Markalarla işbirliklerim olmaya başladı.
Kazancım da artmaya başladı.
Ama şöyle bir şey vardı.
Hâlâ bir şirket değildim.
Hâlâ faturalarımı başkaları
aracılığıyla kestiriyordum
ve bu bana bir külfet olmaya başlamıştı.
Ve ben dedim ki kendi şahıs şirketimi
kurmalıyım ve bu yolda devam etmeliyim.
Kendi şahıs şirketimi kurduktan sonra
o ilk adımı atmak benim için zordu.
Şirket kurmak ama şirket kurduktan sonra
o yola girdim ve her şey belki de daha
kolay bir şekilde çözüldü
çünkü bir yola girersiniz ve o yolda
karşınıza çok fazla şey çıkabilir.
Yani sonunu görmezsiniz ama o yolda
keyifle ilerlemek, o yolun o anın keyfini
çıkararak ilerlemek belki de
her şeyden çok daha önemlidir.
Benim için de öyle oldu.
Şu an sonunu düşünmediğim
bir iş yapıyorum belki.
10 sene sonra ne olacağını hiç
bilmiyorum ama şu anda ben bu işte çok
mutlu bir şekilde yaşıyorum
ilk günkü heyecanımla
çünkü hareket ediyorum.
Ta en başta
üniversitede ne istediğini
ne hayal ettiğini bilen bir Beril
şu an hâlâ bugün buradaysa
o ilk günkü heyecanımla isteğimle
üretmeye devam ederek burada olduğuma
ve bunun zaman içinde
bir karşılık bulduğunu düşünüyorum.
Belki de bu iş imkanını kendim yaratmış
olduğumu düşünüyorum ve
bugün burada olmayı da buna bağlıyorum.
O yüzden umarım herkes benimle aynı
heyecanla yaşayan bir çok insan vardır
kendi istediklerini hayallerini bulabilen.
O yüzden bugün bu hayalinizde isteğiniz
varsa umarım benim gibi bunları
paylaşabileceğiniz doğru platformları,
doğru yerleri bulabilmenizi diliyorum.
Çok teşekkür ederim.